hello everybody my name is
not psycho no sutoka
that's not my name my name is markiplier
and i'm playing psycho no sutoka which
if you remember i played a demo of a
while ago here's a clip of that no no no
hey hi oh mostly that's me screaming but
i played it in between all those screams
now it has a quote-unquote
full release not really
i didn't see that before it's an alpha
2.2.8 release but there's more to the
game than there was before so i
am going to see what all is new with
psycho no sudoka
and
[Music]
disabled
uh
oh
wait i'm kind of curious what is
what does this even mean
is this easy mode i would figure that
yandere
would not be
easy
okay
[Music]
hello
okay
well that seems nice
this seems familiar
wait a minute
is this
wait
is this
is this a building from yandere
simulator i'm very confused i don't know
what's happening right now because i
don't remember the other game starting
out this way yeah it definitely wasn't
bright and cheerful it was dark and
mysterious maybe this looks familiar
because it's just what
japanese schools look like
hi
[Music]
[Music]
you're saying a lot and i i don't think
you're necessarily saying what the
english translation is saying that
you're saying you have a key on your
building really tempted to take it but
i'm not going to because i'm
i wouldn't want to be misconstrued as
reaching to touch your butt and i'm not
that kind of guy
okay maybe in this one
i am
i really am
i'm following you i don't even know who
i'm looking for why would you know who
i'm looking for i'm very confused
but uh nice to meet you my name is
markiplier i don't know if i go to this
school in fact i haven't been in school
for quite a few years now i dropped out
of college
two semesters before i could graduate
but
look at me now
[Music]
what are you looking for
what did i do what do you mean what did
i do whoa
looks like something went wrong in the
power room i'd be sure
[Music]
you know usually you'd call like the
maintenance staff for that but i guess
we're going to go together then
we're just wait i'm
i miss something
why do i have an option to push you i
don't want to push you
i'm a gentleman or something like that
an [ __ ]
sure one of the other take your pick
there's no doubt
[Music]
okay
oh power room well that's convenient uh
hey can you open this for me
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for that
[Music]
you are really
nice you're nice you're nice don't worry
i'll turn my back to you
and solve this don't you worry
hmm
[Music]
got it
all better
okay
you got it was this a can of soda no
okay where are we going who are we
looking for
your head is way too big
what do you mean what am i doing i
didn't do anything you turned on the
light and now you're going to the back
of the room
why
oh oh oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah yeah this um
yeah
he's uh yeah yeah he's god man val i'll
hurry
he's just trembling in fear the prospect
of the situation where there's a dead
body in the closet
that i'm gonna help with her med kit
goodbye
bye
where is
he still there good okay i'll be back
i don't remember this part of the game
at all i don't know where the infirmary
room is
ma'am
where would the infirmary be
okay
headmasters informery
whoa
i'm breathless
where would uh first aid be where would
uh
man i really should have been on the
lookout for some kind of a trap or
something
yeah i don't feel good
what is this
i'm healed
well too bad i wasted that
well
i feel sleepy
i fee i feel sleepy
why do i feel sleepy
what
am i sleepy
i didn't find a med kit i feel dizzy um
well i better lay down then i guess
uh
oh there we go
ah
man
oh that was the intro
for some reason oh mate no maybe not
that's not good
hi
hi
hello
hi
uh
um
wow
[Music]
okay so that was yandere mode i'm gonna
go normal now the question is is this
going to be a different experience than
that
shift use lock crouch important note
please remember that you can only carry
one key at a time in your hand i have
very small hands
just
oh
what did i just see
no hi
hello
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
a little confused here but uh
[Music]
you got to be thorough you got to be
sure about these things
okay
you got it i hear stay no moving
[Music]
i'm a man of my word
i wouldn't i'm not
i was trying to command my word
wow that's probably fine what is this i
can collect pages now
the breaker switches in the storage room
i did not want to do it them sorry okay
cool
that's cool um
[Music]
oh
i'm right here don't kill me i didn't go
anywhere why did i do why why why wow
you're approaching really quickly i
don't need any of this please do not
you can have it oh
uh
i guess i shouldn't have picked anything
take it take it
listen
we can talk this through
everything's fine
i
appreciate you
and everything that you've done for me
up until this point that guy that you
killed just now very annoying
hi
well bye-bye
super actor why would you do this to me
were you choking me
it's a hug it was a hug
i don't know i'm gonna take this now can
i put it away or something
anyway find the code to unlock the space
and get exit key
okay there's a code somewhere
i'm gonna take this oh i don't have any
ailments i'm healthy as a horse
[Music]
oh
there you are where is that is that
right outside this door
god i hope not is that me wow
that's some good stuff
you right outside the door hi
a kick
no no
no no no no i'm going goodbye now
farewell farewell farewell faring well
my well is
fed uh you don't know i'm here do you
you would never know
i'm very good at hiding
very good
okay i guess everything's fine
okay i can crouch
okay
i don't know where these things would be
hidden if they're just in any room
around here what is this
pages are blank good
good green i'll just try to be thorough
sure was this book wasn't in my hand
oh i threw it did i just throw it i
threw it
okay
all right
i don't know where she's gone
boy do i miss her
but uh in the meantime oh hey
i missed you i said it i said it out
loud you heard me right
i'll just
keep going around
oh roof okay well that's fun what is
this oh
page five
ah
okay i don't know how to read this
oh
a brick shooter
bri
what is a brick shooter
oh hey holy what are you doing excuse me
don't mind me
no thank you i locked myself out that's
not what i meant that's not what i meant
that's not what i meant be nice
okay bye
goodbye
hell
super scary
yeah you're real scary there maybe i
shouldn't be playing on normal
oh paige
this doesn't seem to be working oh i
need to spam it that's what i needed
can i have that don't mind me
oh there's someone's blood all over the
floor wow you're quicker than i thought
excuse me ow ow
yeah you hurt me
you really heard me i can't believe you
died i
know
stop it how do i how do i is there a way
to fight back can i push you
you'll never find me in here
you might find me you might find me okay
no no no no no no no no no no push
push ow did you keep me in the balls
[Music]
oh you're warning me
you know you you i
i care about you deeply and uh
you know found d2 dorky that's good
[Music]
god my balls again
[Music]
this is my last chance well
i'm
[Music]
you ain't hey okay i'm slow i'm slow i'm
slow i'm slow i'm slow close now
[Music]
game game let's play a game
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i won
okay thank you
goodbye
all right well that
that's uh
that worked out nicely
ow ow ow
ow
you said you would let me go and you
didn't
[Music]
no i i don't think i am to be honest
okay anyway i was playing on
big baby mode oh there's another ending
to yandere
yangire what does that even mean
let me try oh i just want to see what
this is all about clearly there's
another ending in yandere mode
but uh i'm just driving no stamina in
200 points start the game with stamina
ah running
well this looks disturbing
i need to restore power in the bar
oh boy
okay breaker switches in the storage
room got it
oh this place looks lovely
i'm protected for five seconds
well if i don't know that's what that
was i wouldn't have used it
uh oh
well seems to be a problem i can't even
get out of this room it's a bit of an
issue
[Music]
i uh
oh
perfect
oh my god
oh my god i'm protected for five seconds
you can't do [ __ ]
oh i hate that okay five seconds
probably up i'm gonna go now okay
god don't look back
the answer is not to look back i need to
go to the storage room wherever the hell
that is i'm protected i'm protected you
can't do anything i'm protected
get back demon
get back
oh oh okay that didn't that lasted
exactly long as advertised okay where is
the storage room i don't know this map i
don't know anything about this place
what if i play this on yandere mode
and then i get used to the surroundings
and then i should be able to do whatever
i need to do she's right behind me isn't
she this is a bathroom i should not be
in here
that that i have
i'm protected
hello you can't come in here this is
clearly the men's room this door is open
i could have sworn i closed it
well because you love me
and if you love something you got to let
it go
i have i have a protection page
how about don't
love the outfit but how about don't
oh well thank you for bringing me here
this is where i needed to be
perfect
[Music]
idiot wow hey you messed me up i'm oh
god that hurts well power's coming back
on
[Applause]
all right well i win the power's on
which means i'm going home
right that's what that means right can i
be protected
am i bleeding or something my health is
going down i seem to be dying
okay so
i don't have a code but at least the
lights are on that's nice hey
could you not
you don't know i'm
here okay
everything's fine
you know i turned on the power but it
doesn't seem like the power is actually
on anywhere
which i find to be a problem
okay find the code
the exit is in the safe find the code
the key to the exit in the safe same
thing as before
okay
why does the headmaster have a picture
of
this lovely individual
oh you're right there aren't you
yeah i'm protected apparently which
definitely works i'm in the library now
you can't get me you got to be quiet in
here
i should not run should i
i don't know where the code would be oh
a2 that's probably important
come at me
i can't open these curtains can i you're
right out there aren't you you're right
out there i'll make it a break
don't
you won't i have the key for this oh
god no
is there a body in here
there will be
oh that was the worst time to open that
no you didn't see anything did you do
hey get back xxx0
i recite the ancient code to you get
back
no no no you won't no you won't get back
i have no page anymore oh
god what is
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
i think that was part of the code if i
uh why did you drag me across that again
that was very mean of you to do that why
would you do that to me
very mean oh
uh well okay this oh
my god
okay so the last code is a zero oh you
are so fast
are you behind me still are you still
behind me okay now i'm starting to
remember how to play this game which is
that i need to find the code and then
put in the code and then get all the
keys through the different rooms and
then go in the rooms and then find the
code and then get out of here
i said that in the wrong order but my
intention was right you still buying me
no you're not
please
okay
all right well this is a problem i
always get the wrong door oh my god
please don't be right there you're right
there aren't you
huh he oh
xxx
that doesn't help me at all maybe i
shouldn't have picked this difficulty
because it's pretty difficult i have 16
health
is this going to be the absolute wrong
time to open that
probably
i'm thinking that there is no right time
to open anything
you there
key d3 got it
d3
interesting c1 okay
i shouldn't be running i should what is
that
oh there was a trap
[Music]
uh
hey
i don't even know your name
listen ah
okay
oh oh why
you offered it to me
you offered it you're a liar
you're a lot i'm gonna go back to
yandere mode i'm gonna go back to
yandere mode because at least that that
was nicer
no no no no i won't i'm gonna play
normal mode not nightmare mode
absolutely not nightmare mode no way in
hell i'm gonna play normal mode i know
how to play
therefore i will play extra good
i'm crouched i am so stealthy
no one knows a thing
oh god she's coming oh god get in
you don't know nothing
you don't know nothing about what i'm
capable of lady
okay
where are you
i was at i think i saw you in hall b
i don't know where hobby is oh hobby
that must be right outside this door so
you're looking for me but you don't know
where i am so there's no reason for you
to come in this room
[Music]
maybe that isn't hall b
i don't know where everything is just
yet
i'll see how the there's two wings to
each of these apparently
[Music]
oh hi
aha there you are on the main oh well
time for me oh there's the key i can't
seem to run
i can't seem to run
whoa hey uh excuse me excuse me excuse
me probably what did i get uh what i
can't read the headmaster that's my key
it's the key to the i was locked in
there which i didn't think was the case
because i could get out of the that's a
lot of blood
um well uh i'm gonna go in here no no no
no no no you don't know
[Music]
yeah you're stupid
yeah you're stupid
oh i'm sorry i called you stupid
i'm sorry
[Music]
are you gonna go
your brain trying to take time to
process what's in this room okay goodbye
[Music]
i hear you
there's nothing in here
okay this was a bust but that's okay
i probably still need to turn the power
on but i don't know if i have the key to
this i do
okay
let me just see if there's anything in
here
i don't know if there would be
i'm just seeing
[Music]
okay or maybe i should just hurry up and
do this thing
okay let's do this
[Music]
power's back on that's good
i think
oh god oh god oh god oh god well hey
look uh can i
lock oh god no hey well
you're stupid
you're stupid
okay well
oh my god i'm trying to you slowed me
you slowed me you slowed me there we go
okay i'm going now can i take that i
didn't i don't have the journal where
did the journal go i don't really know
it doesn't really matter i don't really
care it's not a big deal it's not a big
deal it's not a big deal it's not a big
deal it's not a big deal it's not a big
deal it's not a big deal it's not a big
deal it's not a big deal it's not a big
deal it's not a big deal
i'm patient
i'm calm
i'm ready
i'm prepared
you shall not kill me
i know that she waits longer than it
seems so i'm gonna be very patient
i've got time
okay
now let's just carefully
go through
very carefully
okay there's nothing in here
by the looks of it
i didn't check that over there
let me take a peeper
damn
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i don't know why me being quiet has
anything to do with anything but
oh
what is this
oh i have shoes now
oh
[Music]
good thing i saw that
is that blood
that blood
sure looks like blood
that's loud
why is that doing that
oh god is there a key at the bottom of
this or something there is what i get
infirmary well that's
not exactly what i wanted but i'll take
it
okay xxx
great
good
oh oh oh that's mine oh i heard i hear
no you don't no you won't no you won't
you don't know you don't know you don't
know you don't know
you don't know
it's probably gone
probably
no
don't
[Music]
okay what did i get
what key is it c3 okay
that's progress the infirmary key is
right here
in whatever room this is
[Music]
a3 okay a3 i believe
c3 is on
the other side
[Music]
oh hey well
there you are good to see you good to
see you good to see you i gotta go i
gotta get out of here i gotta go
go
go
[Music]
oh god damn it d
well that's a problem
are you behind me oh oh you went through
oh you turned around
stupid
oh
boy oh boy it's our code piece eight
okay first number eight got it excellent
good excellent best
first number is eight
oh god
no how would you know
how would you know
how would you ever know
told you
oh no my power
at least you're all the way in the power
room and that means you're not here
which is good first number is eight
there's probably another key in one of
these other side rooms
first number is eight and there's a
tripwire they're not gonna fall for that
key
damn it
what is this two
what we got a2 okay perfect that's on
the other side of this
a2
first
first one is
eight once i get all the codes i restore
power
[Music]
and then
i'm good
[Music]
okay what have we got
nothing
ah
god damn it
how can there be nothing
that's not fair
that's not fair
unless i can only see it when the
power's on or some [ __ ] like that do
i have to turn the power on
oh is it a thing where i can't oh
[Music]
okay i'm gonna go turn the power on and
i'm gonna come back to a2 and if i find
another key to another place in these
b's
that's bully for me
[Music]
he no that's a glint of light
that's not a key at all
what is this d2 okay
[Music]
that's helpful
wait
wait
wait a minute that was
i swear that wasn't there before that
was how could that have been there
before i walked into this room
okay it didn't do anything to me
what did i get d oh i dropped the key
d2 dorky
okay b1 is still locked
oh
that's rude
ow
why would you do that
why would you do that you may oh i still
have the key you stupid fool
um you'll never find me
[Music]
no you won't
you'll never find me stupid unless you
can see me through the slats which would
be pretty obvious
oh oh she can see me through the slats
she can see me through the slats
she can see me through the slats oh no i
don't want it
[Music]
is it my last chance
all right let me i'm so slow i'm
what where'd you go oh oh god oh god oh
god oh god
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no okay i'm
gonna go this way he fooled you
idiot oh i have shoes on
suck my shoes
i don't know if i'm gonna get away
uh
oh god this is that again i just need to
flip this whoa
no
stop
don't do it
did that turn the power on did that
actually do it it doesn't seem like the
power's on anywhere and i can't see
anything so i'm beginning to think that
the power might not be on
unless it is on it is on okay i have one
number i have one number
now did that do anything to the
possibility of me seeing inside these
rooms
set one or seven what is it one or seven
i don't know
i'm going away
i'm gonna duck this time so that i can't
be seen through the slats
you there oh
it's either one or seven i don't know
i could procedurally try all of the
numbers
until i get what i need unless an alarm
goes off
i think it's a one
i think
i think that's a one eight something one
okay i have to turn that power on to be
able to see the numbers
if i get one more number which there was
in the ds i did unlock another room over
there i can guess the rest
don't be hiding around the corners
please don't be hiding around the
corners oh
[Music]
yeah it's me all right i'm gonna go turn
the power on i'm gonna go to the ds i'm
gonna look for a key i might have gotten
a key but i don't remember
[Music]
oh you went a shortcut way great
i'm worried you say don't worry
i'm very worried that's a whole ass
tripwire
i need to turn this on
oh boy
okay ring around my rosie ring around my
rosie ringing oh i got caught on a door
panel
okay ringing ring rosie has been wrong
this can't be me i've got shoes okay six
eight six one
i could guess the rest
i'm gonna go for it you can't beat me
861
i could guess the rest if i can get in
here close the door get in the in the
thing with the thing
oh did i do it i did it because i'm so
goddamn good
861
something
i can guess it i bet there's no
repeating numbers in it so i'll try
eight six one two three four five seven
and nine i should probably start with
she's right nine the door
okay let's try this
eight six one
nine
eight eight six one
seven eight six one
five
eight six six one four
eight six one three
oh i got it i got it
[Music]
how about no
i don't want to play go away go away i
know i'll regret that i didn't want my
life to rely on just to go
[Music]
slow and painful eh hey
don't promise me with a good time did i
drop that into i have it it's the exit
key i'm out i'm free i go home now i
will never come back here oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] me no no not like this a tripwire i
forgot about the tripwire oh my god not
the tripwire oh my god get me in that
give me give me a new get me into it get
me into it
you know i'm starting to think i can
start thinking you might be a fool i've
got the exit key in my hand
you think you can beat me
you're all the way over in the power
room i'm so beyond the needs for simple
things such as power
you think power can thwart me
at this point i've got a mechanical lock
oh no
not like this
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
senpai's
[Music]
you told me to wait all right you know
what you're right
you're right you're a hundred percent
right and you know what i'm just gonna
wait
right here
for you i'm not going anywhere i'm just
gonna stay right here for you
i'm waiting
[Music]
thanks god
hey what's up
[Music]
hi
[Music]
okay
yeah
love to
hi
why would i ever want to leave
being here with you
is all i've ever wanted
[Music]
promises are so empty
i'll show it with my actions
[Music]
where would i even go
my whole world is here with you
[Music]
no no don't back away from me you're
running away from me
[Music]
oh well you know i
[Music]
it's a little aggressive
i wasn't trying to leave
i really wasn't
hi it's me what did i do
i did nothing
i'm not worried why would i be weird
hey what are you running away from
why don't we go up to the roof
eyes mooch
yes the moon is beautiful tonight isn't
it my darling
let's move this way
yes hello
why does she do that when you open the
door so she really doesn't do anything
if you're not doing anything against her
[Music]
she just follows you
she really does care
ah
i'm so confused
why do you do that
where's the journal come with me let's
find your diary excuse me i need you to
why would i do that
oh oh oh take it take it take it take it
take it take it
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry hey
wow
why would you do that
why'd you do that
explain yourself
nope
[Music]
you nice you nice right now oh she's
nice right now
why would i do that
wow nice jump
[Music]
hey
hey come back here
this this is an interesting behavior for
like an enemy where
they have modes where they're just kind
of like
all over the place and jumping around
and
what have you
[Music]
mode now hey give me that
oh hello
hey my balls all right you gonna murder
me or something are you just gonna
murder me in cold blood the one you love
you gonna murder me you gonna murder me
okay well this is just mean
okay
okay
wham
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't want to go
i don't want to go anywhere
i want to play another game
with you
okay hey you
that's rude
no
i'm not i'm dead now all right
i wasn't goofing around there so that is
psycho knows
there's more to the game obviously that
i have not gotten to look at all these
endings that i didn't get i almost won
but then i didn't and then i almost won
and then i didn't and i didn't even
almost one on this one and then there's
a whole new nightmare mode
so that's fun and uh if you guys want to
see more let me know down in the
comments below i'll play it again i'll
actually try to win this time meaning
that i definitely didn't try to win this
time so
just wait till you see my skill so thank
you and as always i will see you in the
next video
bye-bye
[Music]